comment ça qu'est ce que je fais dans la
vie j'ai dû te dire une dizaine de fois
oui je suis entrepreneur oui c'est ça ça
fait à peu près un an maintenant
et qu'est ce que je fais mes journées
ben écoute je vois mes clients j'en
rencontre nouveau j'essaye d'améliorer
mon produit et parfois même je bosse sur
la communication et à quoi ça sert à
quoi mon entreprise serre et qu'est ce
qu'elle change dans le monde écoute tu
me pose une colle
cet échange aurait pu la voir
vingt fois à un moment de ma vie comme
beaucoup de jeunes actifs et beaucoup
d'étudiants
j'ai voulu travailler différemment j'ai
voulu entreprendre
j'ai voulu prendre les rênes de ma vie
j'avais envie de faire avancer les
choses à ma façon
et finalement on est en dedans je me
suis retrouvé à beaucoup pensé à un
idéal
pensez aux produits que je serai fier de
présenter à mes clients j'ai même pas
trois semaines à réfléchir au design de
mon site internet
imaginez la perte de temps finalement
les objectifs que je m'étais fixé
pendant tout ce temps c'était devenu des
freins et ses freins finalement il ne
faisait agir seulement 20% montant 20 %
de mon temps dédié à la création de
valeur dédié à répondre aux besoins que
j'avais identifié chez les clients ça ne
m'allait pas du coup j'ai décidé de
changer de cap et un moment j'ai rejoint
une grande entreprise un leader du sport
inventé dans 40 pays
vous imaginez j'avais l'impression de
tomber aux antipodes de
l'entrepreneuriat moi qui rêvais de
liberté de pouvoir agir un petit peu
comme je souhaitais de prendre le chemin
qui me plaisait et finalement je me suis
trompé parce que cette entreprise en
pleine libération managériale c'était un
vrai terreau fertile pour les gens comme
moi qui avais envie de travailler
différemment
j'avais envie de changer des choses le
gros avantage entreprendre l'entreprise
40 ans d'activité c'est que tout est
déjà en place
vous savez les outils le réseau toutes
ces méthodes toutes ces choses que des
entrepreneurs se battent des mois et des
années pour avoir c'est déjà là j'avais
plus qu'à surfer dessus
imaginez juste deux minutes vous êtes
entrepreneur et vous pouvez en un clic
accéder à 80 mille clients c'est vrai
quand même imaginer encore vous êtes
entrepreneur toujours et vous avez vous
avez même pas à vous soucier de comment
vous paierez votre loyer à la fin du
mois c'est magique c'est le rêve le rêve
de tous les entrepreneurs j'imagine en
effet en rejoignant cette entreprise
j'avais troquer un petit peu de ma
liberté par contre j'avais gagné
beaucoup d'outils coûts de sécurité
beaucoup de sérénité et en main
franchissant de toutes ces contraintes
je me suis retrouvé à pouvoir réellement
créer de la valeur
agir en lien avec ma passion avec ce qui
m'animait vraiment avec mon sens pour
moi créer de la valeur c'est aider les
ont aidé les autres c'est contribuer à
la réussite de quelqu'un c'est partager
c'est accompagner quelqu'un vers sa
destination rêvée c'est comme ça que je
vois la création de valeur il ya à peu
près une année j'ai saisi l'opportunité
d'animer la vision à 10 ans de cette
entreprise en france je suis sorti d'un
cadre de métier qu'on m'avait donné pour
créer de la valeur à une échelle
beaucoup plus grande que l'entreprise en
lien avec ce qui m'animait vraiment et
j'ai pu vivre ma passion du partage et
de générosité en rencontrant en
inspirant en accompagnant des centaines
d'hommes et de femmes qui étaient à bord
a dit qu'ils étaient les étudiants à ce
moment là je me sentais beaucoup plus
heureux je me sentais beaucoup plus
accompli j'ai longtemps pensé que la
l'équation de l'entrepreneuriat
finalement c'était une belle idée et de
la finance puis que cela générerait un
résultat et aujourd'hui je suis
convaincu d'autres choses aujourd'hui je
suis convaincu qu'en reprendre s'est
trouvé sa singularité plus de l'action
au sein d'une structure celle qu'ont
choisi et ça c'est créateur de valeur et
puisque je parle de singularité je vais
vous en donner un exemple très concret
je vais vous parler d'al ain
c'est un ami un petit peu loufoque
qui croit tellement fort que ce qu'on
possède fini par nous posséder qu'il a
décidé de ne plus posséder deux maisons
vous imaginez quand même mec du jour au
lendemain dit moi je ne veux plus maison
je suis à la rue il a une activité qui
lui permet et qui lui demande de
beaucoup voyager
donc pendant ses voyages il a décidé de
loger
j'ai des collègues aux quatre coins du
monde en partant de cette singularité de
cette chose qui le rend unique à lanne a
créé un service d'hébergement
collaboratif dans son entreprise qui
permet à tous les collaborateurs en
déplacement professionnel d'être hébergé
par un autre collègue dans la
destination choisie vous imaginez plutôt
que d'aller à l'hôtel vous vous
retrouvez à visiter une nouvelle va
découvrir une nouvelle culture ou même
essayer un nouveau sport accompagner
quelqu'un à bà nà locale quelque chose
de merveilleux
alan était partie de ces grandes et
unique ils croyaient réellement que le
partage rapprocher les hommes
il a agit au sein d'une entreprise
il s'est appuyé sur ce qui existait déjà
et il a créé de la valeur est pour lui
créer de la valeur s'était permettre à
des gens de se rencontrer
permettre à des gens de partager
maintenant j'ai envie de vous demander
est ce qui vous rend unique vous qu'est
ce qui fait que vous êtes régulier dis
moi qu'est ce qui fait que tu aies
singulière qu'est ce qui fait que tu
aies singulière et qu'est ce qui fait
que tu aies singulier pensez-y deux
minutes une fois qu'il aurait trouvé
cette singularité qui est un peu le
point de départ de toutes vos actions
trouver une structure une structure
n'importe laquelle qui vous permettent
d'agir très vite de vous mettre en en
marche
peut-être que cette structure ce sera la
start-up que vous envisagez de créer
dans deux mois avec votre voisin et tant
mieux peut-être que ce sera l'entreprise
dans laquelle vous travaillez déjà
depuis trois ans ou peut-être même que
cette structure ce sera l'association
dans laquelle vous vous investissez
finalement conçoit entrepreneurs ou
intrapreneurs l'important c'est de
trouver sa singularité et d'agir
rapidement de trouver comment vous
souhaitez créer de la valeur
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez apporter au
monde comment souhaitez aider les autres
et de se mettre en mouvement
vous avez toutes les cartes en main pour
résoudre l'équation
j'espère que vous allez créer encore
plus de valeur que vous ne le faites
déjà étant maintenant tu sais ce que
c'est que d'entreprendre tu as compris
merci
[Applaudissements]